knives out that's the focus of tonight's
angle
all right record high gas prices markets
collapsing with the s p entering the
bear market territory china's
threatening war over tairan to taiwan
and on the number one issue facing
americans well we tried to warn them
former clinton treasury secretary larry
summers has been warning about the dark
clouds forming over the biden economy
for months
data are pointing more towards higher
inflation these are simply not serious
people
if they were they would invite larry
summers to the white house to give the
entire cabinet and senior staff like ron
klaine a tutorial in basic economics
every single person on his economic team
should be fired in fact anyone who
advised the president that inflation was
transitory should resign or be
terminated
but joe biden in whatever combo of jill
his sister and hunter have kept the
whole plate thing spinning these past 18
months they're refusing to budge on
policy or personnel
they decided just i don't know deny
reality as long as possible
i see important transitory influences at
work and i don't anticipate that it will
be
permanent but most of the price
increases we've seen are were expected
and expected to be temporary
was it wrong to consider inflation
transitory we have to address the fact
that
we got to deal with the fact that folks
are pa paying for gas paying for
groceries and are are
need solutions to it if we want to get
inflation down i think
continuing to make progress against the
pandemic is the most important thing we
can do
oh that's my favorite at the end now no
matter how much americans were and are
suffering no matter how low biden sinks
in the polls the white house would not
and will not change course
what is the grand home plan to increase
oil production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious wood that i had the
magic wand on this
well i can tell if voters had a magic
wand they'd want to make herd disappear
from the cabinet
their steadfast refusal to change course
despite the ongoing damage the american
family
it's really the definition of fanaticism
now remember they've convinced
themselves that the reason voters are
unhappy
is only because their message hasn't
been able to break through yet
so supply chain issues that's a comms
problem
120 to fill your tank for your suv
that's a comms problem no baby formula
that's just bad pr biden so desperate
he's even hitting the press at this
point
why don't they publicize all the good
he's done for america there's a lot of
major things we've done
but what we haven't done is we haven't
been able to communicate it in a way
that is uh um
i might say another way well see that's
kind of perfect yeah i've been able to
communicate but look how the press has
changed it's just everything gets
gets sensationalized in ways but i'm
convinced we can get through this
how incredibly insulting to the american
people
this is sensationalized
just to get to school and home every
single day it's costing us 115 a week
it's painful to go to the gas station
and i think we're all just feeling that
i need jesus and all other saints to
come and help me it's too much
his policies are inflicting real pain on
real people
and he expects that no one's going to
report on it
the fact is their agenda though is
working as planned isn't it
in order to hit their climate change
targets to reset capitalism as klaus
schwab from the world economic forum put
it
americans must become poorer period
and that's exactly what's happening now
the vendetta against domestic oil
production production and their desire
for open borders of course the war in
ukraine more printing of more money more
borrowing more racial recriminations
they're doing exactly what they're
designed to do
usher in a necessary period of american
decline
so the european model of high gas prices
more government spending less personal
freedom that was always their preferred
path
because it was considered far superior
to anything the traditional american
approach could offer
so this far left viewpoint once limited
to college campuses
now defines the democrat party
now as the angle predicted during the
campaign of 2020 a feeble-minded grifter
like joe biden he was too weak or too
stupid to resist this more
ridiculous left-wing path for a more
sensible one
but even after joe biden did everything
they asked supported every idiotic
growth-killing policy the left pushed
the democrats have still pulled the
switchblade on them
since they can't blame their own
policies for bringing ruin to the
average american
they too believe it's all a pr problem
and if it's a pr problem they need a
better messenger in 2024 for their
social and political revolution
both the old and the new guard are
tossing biden to the curb even before
the midterms
david david axelrod told the new york
times the presidency is a monstrously
taxing job and the stark reality is that
the president would be closer to 90 than
80 at the end of a second term and that
would be a major issue
and here's what went down when aoc was
pressed about 2024.
president biden he is saying he's going
to run again in 2024 will you support
him
you know if the president chooses uh to
run again in 2024 i mean first of all
i'm focused on winning this majority
right now
and preserving a majority this year in
2022 so we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
try to diagram that sentence
even his own press secretary doesn't
feel comfortable talking about biden's
reelection campaign
is the president running for reelection
he has ant
first of all
let's reset for a second i cannot talk
about
elections the president as you know has
been asked that question many times his
answer has been pretty simple which is
yes
okay this is all just an epic cast off
so this is what i'm telling you tonight
welcome to the lame duck administration
and biden and his family are somehow i
guess surprised by this
had he worked with republicans he had
taken a more moderate approach he'd be
more popular with america but he would
have alienated the radical and powerful
forces in his own party he couldn't do
that
now for a sneak peek into the democrats
intransigence on policy and approach
look no further than the january 6
hearings today
now we couldn't help but notice the
bottom right hand corner of the screen
where a graphic was showing the bottom
falling out of the markets
now so as americans struggle in 2022 the
democrats can't stop talking about 2020.
an attack on the american people by
trying to rob you of your voice in our
democracy and in doing so
lit the fuse that led to the horrific
violence of january 6th they marched on
the capitol at his request and hundreds
of them besieged and invaded the
building at the heart of our
constitutional republic
oh my god play that in gitmo and they'll
get all the information they want now
even the media knows this isn't going to
help them
even if it doesn't change people's votes
in the midterm elections democrats think
that this is an existential crisis for
american democracy when i go out um into
the states and have been recently
talking to people that's what people
tell me that they're really focused on
gas prices and all the different things
that are making life more expensive for
a lot of people americans aren't focused
on these hearings in the way that we are
that doesn't mean
yeah that doesn't mean check out the new
ibd poll biden's approval rating sank to
its lowest level and the latest uh poll
for investors business daily with just
37 percent of american adults approving
of how he's handling the presidency the
poll also found that 90 of americans are
concerned about the path of inflation
over the next 12 months 53 percent think
we're already in a recession
yet again the democrats persist
no personnel changes
no policy changes
ride this lame horse of big government
big green socialism right into midterm
oblivion
i don't know i was thinking about the
same maybe the democrats truly believe
that they can convince americans to
accept a lower standard of living
after all for decades corrupt liberal
leadership it's plagued cities like
baltimore or detroit hartford
connecticut yet
these cities keep voting for democrats
election cycle after election cycle
so when will this end
the truth is though democrats won't
change they won't jettison the far left
until they're forced to
bill clinton was smart enough to pivot
in 1994 that democrat party though has
long since been buried
in 2024 they're going to need to suffer
a 1984 style wipeout in order for us to
restore america
and whether they run mayor pede or amy
klobuchar or kamala it's not going to
matter
their core policies will not change
and the outcome for american taxpayers
for seniors for young people will be the
same
despair and decline
only with a new messenger
it will not work and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else